foreign
two versions of the same blade
One winner
forged in fighter weapons Showdown we're
sending you back to your home forges to
recreate an iconic weapon from history
that weapon is
h
sweet each blade must pass three tests
the Sharks test
kill test good luck placements we'll see
you in five minutes all right the flight
is curving one when I'm forging the edge
of the blade you can't get it straight
before grinding you just will start over
having to keep the blade straightened
throughout the forging process of
putting it behind because I can't move
and blade as fast as I need to I'm
feeling a little nervous about the heat
treat all right the moment of truth I'm
Edge clutching hoping for a hard edge
and a soft spine therefore reinforcing
the blade
foul test oh yeah we got her yeah I have
a little concern about the weight a
little bit in front heavy does bother me
a little but at this point not much I
can do about it my goal is to get the
rough shape and stuff knocked out as
fast as I can because I really like to
spend as much time as possible really
showing my creativeness so I got my
metal in the quench tank it's flaming up
I'm more worried about glistening for
cracks or anything than I am about
burning my shop down at the moment I'm
going to try to incorporate maybe like a
dragon type thing on one side and maybe
a bunch of uh just designed on the other
so then I'll put that in acid it'll eat
away everywhere beside the paint so it's
just one big piece of art as well as a
weapon the sharpness test
thank you
it feels good it's got a good balance to
it the shape of this is really nice The
Cutting Edge curved like that sharp
weapon
well right off it's definitely sharp but
it weighs a ton I like the design of
this but build strong doesn't
necessarily mean build heavy the
strength test
thank you
nice
well John you're uh bardish it's got a
nice weight to it I'm looking at the
edge it held up beautifully everything's
still straight and tight good job thank
you oh boy
all right
[Music]
oh
Michael first things first
this thing is heavy everything is still
tight there's no Motion in it even after
all of that chopping and smashing of
skulls The Edge held up really well so
well done the kill test
[Music]
all right John's talking about your
bardish here I love the swells your
blade right here is razor sharp cuts
through spine bones and thick flesh
overall sir your bardish
will kill
[Music]
okay
all right Michael this is at least
around 11 pounds all forward weight
I waste so much energy in recoiling that
could be used in a tank but overall sir
your badish will kill yeah John Mike you
bladesmiths have engaged in one of our
most difficult competitions however only
one of you can be the forest fire
champion and that champion is
John congratulations you're our new
forged and fire Champion Mike you
brought us a weapon that's got a lot of
artistry that went into it but in the
end it just has so much weight that it
wasn't an effective bar dish that's why
we're letting you go my experience here
was definitely challenged pushed me to
my limits I learned a lot I might not be
the fortune fire Champion but I still
feel like I'm walking away a winner John
congratulations you're the new forged
and fire champion and that is a title
that comes with a check for how much in
Graham I'm super excited to get home and
tell my wife about the great news and
wonderful year thank God